ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show big announcement
uh is part of why we are a little late
with the show the show is moving to
spotify exclusively
nothing will change about the show uh
we're going to be exclusive to spotify
for audio and video
they've negotiated a deal with us that
will be coming out in the news
very soon which is really cool we're
negotiating right now with the
ceo spotify uh bring him up
this guy and the negotiations have been
uh his name's daniel elk he's the guy
here and he's like a bald
uh norwegian pedophile and he's we're
negotiating with him
and what's hard about doing that is
every time we try to do that he's
[ __ ] children and blowing their
brains out uh
in sweden or wherever the hell he lives
and then throwing their lifeless corpses
over his viking ship into the ocean that
being said
this bald person has given us
a really good indication that we're
going to be
on spotify of course you know the uh
platform where they rob
uh musicians who are mostly brain dead
drug addicts so
we've uh uh we said we don't have a
problem with that we especially like
that they're to keep robbing musicians
and taking the little drug money
uh that these people have left but
daniel eck is it acker elk
it's eck that's part of the negotiation
is we pretend not to know his name
uh but daniel ack who is a uh a nazi
viking pedophile uh
the ceo of spotify uh we try to
negotiate with him and we get on all
these zoom meetings
and on every zoom meeting and this is
true he's got behind him he has the nazi
flag and he has so much cool nazi
memorabilia
that's so hard to get it's so hard to
get
the things he has and they're always
displayed
behind him spotify um but we were
surprised at the offer
which is right now the
offer is 18
billion dollars and we're
shocked at um he says he wants to build
a new
epstein island to train nazi youth with
us and i'm excited about that
unvaccinated nazi youth
on a new island daniel eck is it ecker
elk
ex ceo of spotify
we have a new deal with spotify for a
trillion dollars to launder
human trafficking and drug money through
our podcast
uh at spotify and that's why we were
late we were late because
daniel ack the ceo of spotify
has offered us uh a deal
so if we can if we can
use it uh in his words
to awaken people about the problems that
the white race
are facing his words not mine
i said we could try it's not usually
what we do
spotify ceo daniel
eck asked us um
to uh be on exclusively his platform
does that excite you at all
i'm stoked i'm very happy to be honest
did you ever think this day would happen
never
i never thought it would but i'm kind of
happy it did me too
at spotify i like spotify
i like it i like that you can't use the
app
and i like that the um
the ceo is clearly in some
nazi viking uh cult
i mean can you not see him on a viking
ship i could see that yeah
just whipping people
i like him he's a good guy
yeah well
can i be the first to say thank you to
spotify
for all of that money
i hope nothing we've said today will
hurt because we're in
open negotiations with him
and he like told us he's like don't
mention like the pedophile nazi stuff
on air but it's not i don't think it's a
big deal
but that's why we're late so i want to
spotify
uh ceo doing big uh
business with us not fake business real
business uh i'm also in the middle of a
home renovation in austin texas
i'm not going to give that woman the
business today i've decided oh really
yeah i didn't like the face the comment
at the end
the comment at the end ruined it we went
into a father
a family a family uh tile place
father and daughter right i thought it
might have been husband and wife
but it was father daughter and we
proceeded to look at all the different
tiles and the things
because i have to i have to get new tile
for my kitchen floor
whether i keep it or rent it or sell it
the tile is bad
we have to get new tile and i went in
and um
i asked for marble immediately why
because it lets them know
that i don't care about them and they
don't matter
to me and if they die or people like
them die
people like me don't get upset do you
see what i mean
when natural disasters affect those
people
i don't care that's why i ask for marble
up front like when i walk in i go hey do
you guys have
marble here and she's like real marble
and i'm like
yeah real marble when a tornado blows
through your mama house
i don't care about that
diabetes-infested [ __ ] i don't give a
[ __ ]
okay so i said this so she and i thought
i
thought it was a uh a husband and wife
but it was a father daughter
i think so yeah tile business and we we
were very not and they dissuaded me they
said marble's too expensive and they're
probably right probably right they're
probably right it's too much
it's too much and marble tiles for
[ __ ] froot loops anyway you want
chunk marble chunks of it
flown in from italy but we can't do that
so
they said porcelain right and that's
good good it's durable
i don't want to put linoleum up well
that's probably how they grew up and
there's nothing wrong with that right
because
linoleum you can piss and [ __ ] on and
just throw orange juice on and
it doesn't bother anyone you can just
get on your knees and wipe it up with a
rag
but anyway so i walk in i got out of uh
the car with you and we were just
trying to you know and so and then i was
really hyped about doing business with
these people
truly but then we gave our phone numbers
at the end and
why don't you tell them what happened so
she asked for both of our phone numbers
that's correct can i give away your area
code for the story i guess i have to
right
you yes the area code was in l.a right
she she said they said to ben what's the
area code i said three
i said three two five blank blank blank
blank blank right and they go oh three
two five i go abilene texas they go
nice right and then they go well they're
like that
they like the area could have abilene
texas by the way the people who cannot
afford to buy the tile
and they go to about you and you you
give your number and they said what's
that
and i went beverly hills and they went
she went
uh she made a face and i joked around i
said don't worry we're voting republican
but we're throwing away this we're
throwing around disgusting amounts of
money
i said we're going to throw away this
around this and she kind of made a face
but here's the that's why i have to deny
the business because of that
i really have to deny the business
here's the other thing if you work at a
family business
in the tile thing for your father the
reality is
you you like sucking his [ __ ]
there's no other way to really
if you work in a family business with
your dad
you like to suck his [ __ ] or you want to
suck his [ __ ]
you want to [ __ ] him you are unable to
find a man
to then go and build a life with you
want to be near your father
and there's a moment out of every single
day
when you want to get on your knees and
suck the old man off
and just say [ __ ] you god and
jerk his old sweaty dick into your mouth
and
swallow his semen and i find that
unnatural it's not with the laws
of nature so i have to take the business
away from these people
unfortunately i have to call them early
in the morning tell them that we have
some uh there's some family emergency
i didn't like her face though very over
the top it was
over the top and you know what here's
what you're gonna have to understand
okay you dumb hick
people like me and other people from
california are gonna move in here are
they gonna make your children trans
of course they are dummy but if you had
enough money none of this would happen
you know that capitalism that you people
just jerk off all day
and you take its [ __ ] and you jam it
down your throat here's what capitalism
means
dummy it means that rich people from
california can move into your turd state
and do whatever they want turn your kids
trans
buy your kitchen tile vote for higher
taxes
fund antifa they can do anything and you
can't stop them you know why
because they got the [ __ ] money and
all you [ __ ] give a [ __ ] about
is money right
so shut the [ __ ] up okay
you live in a suburb of austin texas the
worst city in america there's three icu
beds here okay
how i mean literally there's like no icu
beds and stars are bad
it's so embarrassing it's it's i i've
been very clear about my feelings for
austin texas
but again you're rah-rah americanism and
obsession with like
capital i do mother well guess what
capitalism means
[ __ ] it means that i can go
anywhere i want if i have the money and
ruin your life
if i want to ruin your life i can now i
have no interest in ruining your life
i don't vote i really have never voted i
don't like lines
but the point is that the people coming
here are going to ruin your life the
tech people are going to come here
and they're going gonna do everything
you think they're gonna [ __ ] do
i'm telling you do you think this
vaccine is bet they're gonna have more
vaccines and i'm
vaccinated i don't even think this one's
there's gonna be new ones that are
coming they'll be
vaccines every three months and they'll
just give them to you when you're
sleeping you're not going to be able to
do anything about it because you don't
have any money
you see the problem you people are all
obsessed with guns and guns are great
and i understand god but you don't
really do anything with the guns we have
a massacre every year no one's impressed
right
see the thing is it's not like you're
organizing assaults on
centers of power you're shooting trees
in your backyard
and the tech people are slowly choking
you
they're slowly taking all the oxygen out
of you and all you're doing is countless
my money
i like my money so if you like capital
it's capital baby that's
it people can come here and do whatever
the [ __ ] they want
and you're gonna have to deal with it
and if you don't [ __ ] like it well
too [ __ ] bad you have to make enough
money to
stop them how about that you've got to
make more money than the tech people and
good luck
good luck slinging linoleum tile if
you're going to have more money than
them
so i don't think i can give her the
business it saddens me because i
actually think they do
a good job they did yeah they were good
but i just i don't i just you know what
it is
it's that over-the-top cuntiness that to
me i
feel like you know what
when i saw her do that i i had a feeling
you were going to back out of the whole
thing
it was a reality it was over the top
well you know what it is
she doesn't understand that she doesn't
have any power we didn't fight through
lines of people to get in there
okay we were the only people in there
but she doesn't and the father
the father even looked you're like kind
of like why are you doing that why don't
you just come suck my [ __ ]
because they want to [ __ ] each other
it's incest it's truly incest
and and that's okay because they have
all these weird codes you're like i
don't like democrats but
i like sucking my daddy off
like even when she was like playful like
he came over she's like daddy don't step
on my clothes because he stepped on her
you know people in austin like women in
austin are um uh disgusting
and they were like she was wearing like
balloon green balloon pants and
everything
because they don't know how to dress
here the women the women here are like
uh
you know they're cows you know they're
like disgusting drug addicts
so uh she's wearing like a green balloon
pants and he stepped on and she's like
daddy don't step on my pants
but i thought she want at that point i
think like he wanted to just kind of
just hit her in the ass like if we
weren't there i think he would have just
taken his big hand
and just hit her in the ass and then
snuck a finger up
snuck a finger up the back and then they
would have went back and like
[ __ ] on like tile like you know like i
like to [ __ ] my daughter on cold tile
i like to [ __ ] i like to feel it on cold
[ __ ] tile
because they're doing incest is my why
my why i say that
um it's summer camping season let's talk
about pitching tents that's right the
episode is sponsored by blue chew
guys confidence can take you far in life
it can also help you in the bedroom
especially when it comes to step up the
plate step up to the plate
step up to the plate the plate the plate
that's where blue chew comes
in pluto makes your dick hard men
everywhere are excited to see the
postman because when your package has
arrived your
package has arrived they always say
first impressions are important but what
about lasting impressions
it's time to get off the couch and back
to work if your tool needs an upgrade
head to bluetooth.com guys there's
nothing sexier than confidence and
bluetooth can help give you confidence
where it counts
all you have to do is go to
bluetooth.com promo code td it's easy
medical professionals help prescribe you
the best
uh whatever for you the [ __ ] dick
[ __ ] and it's good it's
got the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis putting chewable
tablets at a fraction of the cost
you can take them any time day or night
so you can plan ahead be ready whenever
an opportunity arises the process is
simple it's bluetooth.com
promo code td consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days the best part it's all done online
so no visits to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations no waiting in line
at the pharmacy
we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code td to check out just
pay five dollars shipping bluetooth.com
promoted
the companies that advertise on this
show are great products sheath underwear
is my favorite
put it on sheath underwear s
h s-h-e-a-t-h underwear it's great it's
underwear it's great it's a
bathing suit um robert pat
pat patron patron patron patron
who's the owner of sheath underwear um
uh is great he served in the united
states
military honorably
and continues to be a leader
for people now
do you know his story because he's
they're saying people like this don't
exist i met him he seemed like a great
dad and
great family well and you know what's
crazy about that what
robert patron is a virtuous pedophile
meaning he's attracted to children
infants
but doesn't do anything about it amazing
sheath underwear.com use the promo code
tim to save 20
do it and it supports our show and it
supports him not
[ __ ] kids austin warns of catastrophe
as texas again becomes center of
pandemic
austin should be warning of catastrophe
regardless of the pandemic
by the way the situation is critical
desmar walks austin travis county's
health authority said in a statement our
hospitals are severely stressed and
there's little we can do to alleviate
their burden with surging
cases
austin only has six available icu beds
um and they've only got 313
available ventilators and most of those
ventilators
being used to smoke brisket
as you can tell major issues here but
here's the thing i will say about austin
did you read this because i was
there is a massive influx of
um the hollywood people coming here
and read the hollywood reporter because
i was quoted in this article
yeah i was quoted in this there's a
massive influx
of people here i was shocked i almost
had to eat my words
because you know me i tend to believe
that if they're gonna write an article
like this it's going to be
has-beens or people who aren't relevant
or people that nobody cares about okay
no no go back to the top but in in
in all fairness to the hollywood
reporter
they have lo this is true they have
located
some a list
stars the types of people where if you
bumped into them
have you ever felt stunned in the
presence of another human being
because these people that have decided
to leave
los angeles for austin are top
level talent top tier
celebrities these are not people where
you do like a double take
this is like they need security
famous worldwide michael jackson types
princess diana
ready let's do it as stars
like stephen amell and zachary
levi flock to the texas capitol
dude i mean
this is did you even know they were here
i didn't know
get get them up please because i they
i'm not trying to make a joke
i'm not kidding about this they're here
in austin
hold on stephen bell
is a canadian actor producer an
occasional professional
professional wrestler known for playing
oliver queen green arrow on the cw
series arrow the show that started the
arrowverse i had thought that the
hollywood reporter
would write an article about like c-list
people
but i was wrong so we have the uh this
guy
he's an actor and a part-time
professional
wrestler zachary levy pew is an american
actor comedian and singer
he received critical acclaim for
starring as chuck bartowski
in the series chuck and as the title
character in
shazam
this is here's the question yeah will
hollywood survive it's not
funny because there's a lot of good
people
in california we all hate the business
but there's a lot of people in there
that have families and with this type of
exodus
with the power players in hollywood
deciding to leave
to come to austin texas keep going down
because it doesn't end
there ben it doesn't stop
there okay now this guy jason uh
padalecki oh jared padilla jared
padalecki is like the big austin
advocate he's uh
padalecki he's been here since 2010. and
uh he's done some stuff go down because
he
he is on some big shows uh i don't know
they don't
he is on stuff but
james james van der beek is here
from dawson's creek james van der beek
has said hey [ __ ] you hollywood hey [ __ ]
you
do you know what he you know how he do
you know james van der beek left
hollywood how
he walked into paramount studios in
hollywood because they offered him a
seven picture deal
because someone there just saw dawson's
creek mind-blowing
someone just saw it and said where's
that guy
now they bring him into paramount they
said
seven picture deal but you have to live
in california
he said hey [ __ ] you he goes have you
ever heard of the texas hill country
and he just walked out dude
20 million dollar upfront guarantee
seven picture deal
he said no james vander pick listen to
scott eastwood adrian pilicki adrian
grenier from entourage the hit new show
and james van der beek from dawson's
creek the hit new show
listen to this at the park in beverly
hills near the house we just moved away
from
you're not allowed to fly a kite
then the beak growls on instagram as he
moved
the beak that's what they call james van
der beek
the beak the beak growls
on instagram as he moves his family to
texas this november quote
also not allowed at any park in beverly
hills riding a bicycle
climbing a tree learning anything from
an instructor
using weights when people at now by the
way
what i don't think this is true
this isn't a lot of it's not true but
i love that he's like climbing a tree
you
hey get off the tree scumbag
hey scumbag i hope james van der beek's
children
get paralyzed from falling out of a tree
where they are literally like literally
i hope
he has to like wheel his son in a
wheelchair
like into austin and his sons like this
hey and james van der beek
and they they go up to him they go dude
i read that i hope it happens soon
dude i read that [ __ ] article
about why you moved to austin it's so
true it's so true dude like you can't
climb a tree and the kid just like
and they go what happened to him and i
hope james van der beek has to go
well i was encouraging him to climb a
tree to be a real man
and he fell and i i didn't catch him
because i was
googling myself and then he broke his
neck and now he can't walk
um but the good news is here's the good
news
the good news is that he can fly a kite
now in the park now not him but we tie
it to his wheelchair
and then push him around
james van der beek you can't learn
anything from an instructor using
weights
these are just some of the reasons more
freedom
was also a motive often expressed by
arguably the most influential
newcomer
[Music]
regime who is this
who is this guy joe regan
joe regan american comedian
podcaster and ufc color commentator he's
a former actor a television presenter
rogan began his career in comedy regan
joe regan interesting he lives here now
we're kidding of course joe moved here
to open up a comedy club
it is open the let me tell you right now
how much fun did we have the other night
at joe rogan's new comedy club
here it is joe rogan's new comedy club
september 1st
opening night here is the lineup
everybody patrice o'neill
gary shandling craig geraldo robert
schimmel
joan rivers robin williams and me and
tony hinchcliffe september 1st
opening night joe rogan and friends big
show on september 1st very very excited
about this are you excited about this
are you bringing your wife yeah she
wants to do you think james van der beek
will be there
boy i hope so do you think actor and
part-time professional wrestler whatever
that other scumbag's name was
will be there oh zach levi yeah zach
levi by the way uh
can we play padlek padlecky uh tor
showed us his house uh that um ida our
friend
ida al and peg peg
uh showed me this guy's house it's
grotesque it's on
youtube uh the way it's designed can we
look at it because it's the perfect like
austin uh aesthetic which is just it's
like
an old couch where they just throw
blankets on it
and i guess people use those blankets to
cry about that they can't live anywhere
else oh is this it men's health this one
right here or you talking about the
farmhouse
the farmhouse okay yeah i mean this is a
dump
can we play this absolutely
hey d i'm genevieve padalecki hi we're
really really
famous now i know you're shocked to see
us
we're incredibly no he's done stuff
bring up what he's done okay i don't
want people attacking me
i got to live here with these people for
a few months i'm not [ __ ] on these
people
all i'm saying is we have to deal in the
world as it is right
so he is legit oh supernatural he was on
in the show
supernatural and gilmore girls he's one
of the greatest actors that's ever lived
he was in the film house of wax have you
seen house of wax
you're a [ __ ] idiot okay
house of wax is a great daniel day-lewis
jack nicholson him let's go to the house
by the way what if you're noticing
we're burning it here in a way that like
pretty soon our physical safety will be
that we have to leave
do you understand like i actually i woke
up in the middle of the night last night
and i was wondering if it's safe to be
here anymore
you know no truly like i walked outside
and i went is it safe to be here anymore
but that is the future of the show i
believe we'll
we'll have to just get deeper and deeper
and deeper into a
sort of canyon a bunker of some kind
some type of bunker
we gotta talk to dick cheney about how
he did it
but i look it look at this woman with a
hat you know i love these
i'm kidding i love you guys let's see
more of their farmhouse
i hope it's modern chic welcome to our
humble abode here is it humble i bet
it's not humble
that's the joke see it's not humble
it's actually very nice
that's right lots of trees for climbing
this is the main room of our house this
is
was that where the slaves got whipped
watch movies
and eat sometimes and it's too late can
you smell the stench of
slaves as their skin
come flying off their backs we like to
bring in the vegetables
is that where you put the vegetables
where the slave got went
in this area take that hat off crocodile
dundee
take the hat off what is with women in
austin and these [ __ ] hats i don't
know
what the [ __ ] is going on here they all
act like they're on safari and they want
to be because they want to go to africa
and buy
slaves to bring them back to their
modern chic farmhouse
neo farmhouse modern chic it's modern
chic
by the way listen to what this dum-dum
says she i gotta get all plain out of
here soon because i mean
they're gonna come for me we're gonna
see them somewhere for sure i don't
think
i don't know if we'll see we don't go
anywhere like dave they invited us to
join the soho house in austin i'm like
this is a trap i mean it's a literal
trap
i you know what i mean we know one guy
here from clubhouse he's
you know i mean he's a sweet man but i
mean he's brain dead right he's
he doesn't he doesn't have enough oxygen
to his brain which is okay i don't know
it's long covered or
short covered i don't know what it is
and he's a sweet man and i like him but
there's something
in his brain that doesn't function right
i mean that's my take
so we have crocodile dundee here with
the hat and she's talking to her husband
about why the uh
the kitchen because the kitchen is the
soul eats the soul
and by the way now that i have to fix up
this dumb [ __ ] house this is all i do
like all i spend my time doing is have
these like
horrible conversations with like
horrible people because all the people
that work all the people
first of all that work in like the
business of like design for the
the most part like the vast majority of
them they're just
it's not they're not like passionate
about it right so they're just kind of
like
kind of like gla like the best cases
they're glazed over and they're like hey
you know it's nice when the tiles are
cold on your feet
they're cold on your face but you know
that's best case
worst cases they're kind of they're kind
of just like looking off and you have to
go
hello and they're like what and you go i
want a refrigerator
you know and they're like 16 years ago
i killed my son by accident i backed out
of my driveway
and he was on his bicycle i killed him
the marriage didn't survive too long
after that after that i ended up getting
into some gambling debts and moving down
south i'm like
wolf appliances are good no wolf
wolf we want gas
let's play the rest of these uh looney
tunes
grab your food go sit at the table
nothing is
precious by the way and nothing is
precious in this house
let's get me and ray kump in there i
want to bring ray kump through that
house with a with a big
with a big [ __ ] like what are the
biggest things that 711 they have
oh big gulps i want to bring red company
with a big gulp and just ashing
everywhere
and then when she gets angry i go wait a
minute you said nothing now by the way
look at this dump
by the way look at this dump they got a
cowhide rug i mean like
could there be any place that attracts
less of a caliber of people than these
people it's like
sitcom stars who who were
on superhero shows in like 2006
that's what they mean by hollywood they
mean people who were on television
18 years ago in a in a screen suit
running around pretending to save people
continue
i just casual is the biggest thing and
we really want everyone
who steps into this house to feel like
it's their home and they're welcome
so we kind of laugh when people say like
hey shouldn't take my shoes off
like no well there are three dogs inside
and three one
kids yeah chickens and whatever so you
make yourselves at home
yeah exactly we're not precious about
this we love it it's our home but our
home
is your home i also really love it
because not only is it pretty
take the hat off we use everything so
our kids do like to come up here they
grab their pots and pans how do they
grab the pots and pans
and then we come over how do they grab
the pots and pans that's not true
together and how do they grab the pots
and pans
it's [ __ ] impossible they're children
and i'm just gonna get get this going
i think the elf of the shelf likes our
uh
likes our bowl he needs a name harold
harold harold is his name
[Music]
with incoming sex machines what happens
is what happened in san diego big
remodel should i just should i respond
you overdosed
i'm just going to say i have to prepare
the eulogy for your funeral
i have to prepare your eulogy
that's funny that's funny yeah isn't it
funny very funny
continue with this i'm look at look at
these two come on
if you want to test your marriage do a
remodel right
that was a tough one oh my god but we
that's what i've always heard if you
want to test your marriage to a remodel
or
have a kid with brain cancer those are
the two
remodeling your home or having a kid
with brain cancer
and you can't afford to pay the bills
those are actually the real tests of
your marriage
um choosing a cabinet and also a child
with a brain tumor
where the bills are stacking up and you
can't pay them
and um that's a huge test of your
marriage
but it may not be as big of a test of
your marriage
as walking around furniture stores in
that hat
but don't you see what i mean folks
about why it's bad here
yeah skip down the line and then we'll
get out of it i kind of want to see
their backyard
let's see their backyard their
backyard's kind of nice huh what is it
it's pretty they start here it's pretty
and green
everyone's obsessed with green here it's
green
isn't it green we really wanted to
create a an area in an outdoor area
where we could eat some of the plants
and also
play some sports and everything was like
really usable so not only are most of
the plants usable
and edible but our yard everything is
for jumping and
soccer and football and general outdoor
seating
again our yard has a few levels and so
it's nice because you get like this view
of where the kids would go but we'll sit
here we'll cook we'll grill
and then you'll see these are our
kitchen wings that's a beautiful yellow
one
it's a beautiful yard but let me tell
you something you're not famous
right i got and that's okay by the way
it's nicer to have a family than to be
famous
but can we can the hollywood reporters
stop writing
articles that like a rash of famous
people who've decided to live here
no one would know who the [ __ ] these
people are if they walked into [ __ ]
ihop
cut it out truly truly cut it the [ __ ]
out
they're not famous they did the better
thing which is raising a family in the
greenery i'm for that i'm pro family
but let's not pretend that they're like
[ __ ] famous like paparazzi are
[ __ ]
diving over the gate in [ __ ] the hill
country
to get a glimpse of these retards eating
chick-fil-a it's not
true they're not famous there's nothing
wrong with not being famous
but let's be damn [ __ ] sure about it
they're not [ __ ] famous
okay how many [ __ ] views does this
thing even have it's probably more than
my [ __ ] [ __ ] show
850 000. yeah but you know architectural
digest has 5 million
subs so here's the deal it's not a ton
of views
a relative to a house tour of somebody
who is really really famous
okay robert downey jr's home has 25
million views
yeah do you see that you know the
difference he's famous
and they're not hillary duff 7.6 million
hillary duff is
uh famous and she's in pizzagate
people wanted that tour you know that
tour me they wanted to see where the
chamber was
remember when they tried to rope hillary
duff and the pizzagate
because she did she did something stupid
like she uploaded like a photo of a
child
and it was like i don't know what [ __ ]
maybe she does kill a kid i don't know
but she did something stupid and
everybody got into it
i never read this hillary duff shuts
down quote disgusting child trafficking
twitter conspiracy
by the way i'm sorry if you didn't laugh
all the way through 2020 something is
wrong with you
on saturday morning the singer and
actress became a trending topic on the
site when a number of users
made unfounded accusations of child
trafficking against her
based on an instagram story she posted
containing photos of her son
in once of the since deleted pictures
her son could be seen lying down nude
with lotion on his body duff decided to
respond via tweet stating that the
accusations were not only untrue
but they were invasive and offensive as
well everyone bored as [ __ ] right now
i know but this is actually disgusting
quote whoever dreamed this one up and
put this garbage into the universe
should take a break from their damn
phone maybe get a hobby
hillary dizzle
i don't know what she did i'm sure she's
not trafficking children but
you know she'll be in austin too in a
few years
but this is what i mean 850 000 views
is not a lot of views no comparative
compared
to the people that are famous
okay and by the way i'm not telling them
to be
they have a much better life being who
they are
but let's stop this jessica alba
is showing us a home in los angeles
she's got 31 million
views here and these people have less
because they are less uh
and they live in austin texas and that's
okay corona
virus baby we
are the world we are the delta
i need liquid iv dude i've been on the
road i've been
working i it's been tough i've been on
planes i've been doing stand-up
i've been doing podcasting and all that
[ __ ] and i'm telling you right now
the hot summer months are here we need
to be proactive to keep our body fueled
and hydrated making hydration a priority
helps us feel healthier on a day-to-day
basis and fuels us to be our highest
potential
one stick of liquid iv is in 16 ounces
of water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone
i mean you know how run down i get just
on the road you get sick a lot
i get i mean it's tough not only that
but the product tastes great with
flavors like watermelon strawberry and
lemon lime
sounds like summer doesn't it first
thing in the morning before workout when
you feel run down daily hydration
maintenance hangover cure etc
i love it it's great tasting functional
products they make you feel great
there's also a give back mission they've
donated over 11 million sticks to people
around the world
examples lemon lime kyberry passion
fruit guava watermelon apple pie
strawberry
i like watermelon you know what makes it
so
effective is the cellular transport
technology the optimum ratio of glucose
sodium and potassium delivers water and
nutrients into the bloodstream it's a
perfect balance to help you hydrate
more quickly and effectively than water
alone one stick of liquid iv in 16 ounce
of water
hydrates faster and more effectively
than water alone liquid iv is on a
mission
to change the world the company is
donating four million servings in
response to kova 19 products are being
donated to hospitals
first responders food banks veterans and
active military liquidity has donated
over 11 million servings globally
grab your liquid iv in bulk nationwide
at costco get 25 off and go to
liquidive.com use a promo code tim at
checkout that's 25
off anything you order when you get
better hydration use promo code tim
liquidiv.com there are hundreds of
companies out there claiming to compare
auto and home insurance rate but there's
only one who actually does it
get better insurance with gabby and i
know because i've done it gabby is the
one true comparison platform with fast
verifiable quotes not ballpark guesses
use your current policy to find a better
policy comparing
your current coverage with 40 of the top
insurance providers progressive
nationwide travelers all in one place
use your current insurance information
to get started use your current
insurance information
to get started gabby help me find the
right policy gabby customers save 961
dollars
per year on average and they'll never
sell your info so no annoying spam or
robocalls
put your policy to the test like i did
get better insurance with gabby
it's totally free to check and there's
no obligation go to gabby.com
tim doing that's g a b
i dot com slash tim
dillon gabby dot com slash tim
dylan use your current insurance
information to get started it's a free
it's a free and they only show policies
that are the same or better
than your current coverage many of them
at a lower price
ah let's go to the numbers
maybe this is in the u.s california is
leading but california's leading right
now
with a total caseload of 4 million sixty
two thousand
three hundred and sixty nine second is
florida three million two hundred and
forty nine thousand i'm sorry texas a
second
second is texas third is florida two
million eight hundred twenty new york
new york's up there illinois
pennsylvania georgia ohio north carolina
and
jersey round out the top ten
hopefully it's the last splash
of the coronavirus this is my hope and
we can move on from this
it's hot it's boring
it's not exciting i don't want to hear
fauci's name
anymore i don't want to hear about the
cdc
i mean we've gotten to a point where a
worldwide pandemic is boring
you know what i mean were you like oh
it's just the apocalypse again
off it's really become like
troubling where you go i don't even care
anymore i don't even know whether or not
i care
i'm trying to care about another
lockdown because i
i don't think it's good and i think
it'll destroy the country but it's hard
for me to even
care about that i'm trying to care
about being locked inside my house
forever but i've been so
you get so beaten down by the news you
just start accepting things you just
start going well all right
i guess so i mean i can so i i can be in
the yard though right
can we be in the can we be in the yard
or is that not a lad australia has like
12 cases
and they are literally like chaining
people
but australians like that they don't
mind they trust the government they like
the government the government's been
good to australians
australians are simple people all they
really want to do is get drunk and grill
that's really it australians all they
want to do
is get hammered in their backyards and
put meat on a grill
there's nothing wrong with that people
are asking why aren't australians angry
about this
they're perpetually lazy descendants of
criminals
all they want to do when they when you
tell them not to work they're
alright and that's it do you think
australia's like demanding to work
all want to work no one cares
they just want to get bombed in their
house and
put a shish kebab on the grill all they
care about
is grilling and eating it's kind of
interesting
there was this really great show called
instant hotel
and it was on netflix and i watched it
with alan pegg and
uh devon and i allen pegg and they came
to my house and we got addicted and we
binged it
and the reason it was so good was
because they used australians
who were notoriously uh monstrous people
a lot of fans there and we love you
but uh people without any taste or
decorum i mean it's good they have no
idea what's going on
so the idea that they're going to judge
hotels even airbnbs
was a little bit hilarious you know like
they're just grotesque people they're
walking around and they're like
this isn't classy i mean look at this
group these are the people
judging if the hotel is nice or not
right
now this isn't the good group by the way
you got to find the first group season
one people
like with babe and bondi what's good
about it is there's these two gay guys
leroy and brent everyone hates them
um what's good about instant hotel is
they picked these
kind of trashy people and they would all
go after each other
and they were rude to each other and
then the next season they go we want to
get more positive
and and then they ruin the entire show
but the first two seasons of instant
hotel are so great look at babe and
bondi
is this them right here uh yes so so to
the far left right there
is babe and bandai and then brent leroy
and what's great about this is
they all have these airbnbs right they
should do this in america and give those
two
lesbians to kick me off you know feature
their uh property but
it's cool it's a cool show all these
people go around to different airbnbs
and they judge each other's airbnb
and they're spiteful and vindictive and
rude they're classless and
uh they're snobs but of course not based
on any
education or understanding of how the
world works they're not discerning
or interesting or intelligent people
they're they're just kind of uh
grotesque and
uh but what's great about it is it's
really really funny right it's really
really
funny to watch these people um that
truly like
learned how to use utensils within the
last 20 years
start talking about decor truly
australia they've started to learn how
to use like knives and forks
relatively recently they prefer not to i
have friends that live there they
australians prefer to eat meat in with
just their hands
okay now and there's nothing wrong with
that it's sexy and fun over there
everything can kill them they just want
to go to the beach [ __ ] and eat
meat with their hands so everyone's like
why aren't they going nuts over this
lockdown i'm like
this is the best case scenario for them
they don't have to work
they're all descendants of criminals and
all those animals are so poisonous right
they really don't want to go outside
they got bad stuff over there
well they do love going outside they
don't care if they get poisoned
these are also not good criminals right
the hamptons they're descendants of
criminals but criminals that have
succeeded
criminals that are good at crime right
new york money
these people are the ones in britain who
got caught like you know trying to rob a
[ __ ]
you know magistrate or something and
then you know his great granddaughter's
on instant hotel
complaining about the size of the
bathroom i'm just saying it's a real
[ __ ]
it's a real romper room over there and i
enjoyed the hell out of it me and alan
pegg loved it
oh and one of the stars killed herself
go into this
find she killed herself one of the stars
of it
i like a reality tv when someone kills
himself
because then i know it was real
oh yes this is very sad she was persian
ben has to be the conscience of the show
so every now and then ben has now this
woman was a [ __ ]
and i don't and i i don't like suicide
i don't like it because it's it's
i would rather people stay here and be
horrible
australian reality star shea rezai who
found fame on instant hotel in 2017 has
died at age 33
her former co-star mikey jello confirmed
the tragic news to daily mail australia
saying yes it is true
and very sad she had a funeral last
wednesday and her death was a week
before
even though we had not spoken for years
i will always cherish the fun time
she had a good heart and would always be
the life of the party she was a very
vicious woman on instant hotel
i think it was drugs
[Music]
yeah so i mean that's sad but again it
shows you
um it shows you that this was
reality tv yeah yeah you're right about
the drugs thing what is it
i've heard from multiple sources she was
using drugs heavily yeah
well people were worried about her on
the show but the problem is the drugs
were really good for the show
that's the problem unfortunately a lot
of times when you produce reality
television
you're it's a catch-22 because you're in
this position
of putting out something that's good or
respecting
human life you can't do both
i mean i'm telling you i've sat down
with some of these people some of the
most
i mean you want to talk about a blank
look in their face
some of the i mean i'm talking about
sociopaths
some of the the coldest people that i've
ever had
interactions with produce reality
television shows
like like things that you wouldn't even
like cupcake wars like i'm the producer
of
cupcake wars and it's like you're
talking to them and you realize that
they're like donald rumsfeld
and you're like yeah i heard one of the
women in there her marriage fell apart
and they went bankrupt and
she's like well there are things you
know there are things you don't know
and there are things you don't know you
don't know i'm like what
excuse me but that's how cold
and uh calculated some of these people
are
um but instant hotel is a real pick
from me australia expands coveted
lockdown over concerned virus
has spread from sydney some of these
cities have locked down with no
cases yeah why they don't care lock it
down
forsters australian for beer
lock it down they don't give a [ __ ] all
right
all right no work it's no work huh
all right sounds good
yes let me know when they need me back i
don't know i coughed earlier
i'll just stay home i try to do an
australian it's hard because it becomes
british
um but you know hopefully this is the
last splash they can't arrest all of us
rand paul
you know dude his hair's out of control
he's like leading the charge right now
against like
i know but i mean it's the the problem
with him is he just
looks like fievel
you know what i mean like i some of his
stuff i do agree with but like
i just i i just
why is the spokesman for all of the why
is everything like the worst
spokesman ever i mean this looks like
a guy that is like trying to like sell
you like a
dodge dart
i mean it's
i mean like go to the go to the
can you play the uh the the guy trying
to make us get the vaccine
from the urban ohio play the
urban the urban outreach program for the
vaccine
look that's megan mccain at the olympics
that's nice
okay let me find this one second
magazine
i believe it was in arkansas and they
were running it on like on youtube ads
before
yeah i mean this is it is just
phenomenal as we know
uh a lot of the people in the urban
community the black community do not
trust the vaccine and i wouldn't either
because of the tuskegee experiment and
many of the other problems
uh we have not i mean can we say this
the us government has not been
good to the black people is that are we
allowed to say that
so many of them are inherently skeptical
of the vaccine
so as in outreach to that uh our
government who has spent
uh years and years and years lying to uh
people of color and uh putting them in
jail for no reason
and all kinds of crazy [ __ ] um
they have an urban uh an outreach
to people and
and this is somebody trying to make me
the vaccine during the pandemic my
lifestyle drastically changed my income
came to a screeching halt you have to
understand i'm a hustler i'm a legit
entrepreneur i sell things
i come in contact with people all the
time i have to stay safe
i didn't have a choice but to trust him
why does this seem racist
do you understand what i mean why do i
start to cringe when he's like i'm a
hustler i sell thanks
what are we doing here who in arkansas
thought this was a good idea i'm a
hustler i sell things i'm not going to
say what i sell
it's not my it's not your business i
make [ __ ] happen i know a guy it's like
why are we what is this
what is going on here first of all it's
also a bad idea because if you're not a
hustler an entrepreneur
you go i don't need it right you're
trying to
like broaden the scope of people you
want to get it what if there's a guy who
goes so i'm not an entrepreneur at all
i work at little caesars i don't need it
but it seems racist and i don't know why
but let's finish it up all right
let's start it over because it's insane
during the pandemic my lifestyle
drastically changed
my income came to a screeching halt you
have to understand i'm a hustler i'm a
legitimate by the way
what car is he
an old ford mustang it's an old ford
mustang now he's outside of the building
we don't know where
we don't know what that building is
t-r-o-i-s
that's the end of the bit we don't know
but he's just posted up
on an old ford mustang in a parking lot
being an entrepreneur he's not at a desk
he's not in an office
they didn't put him in an office the
state of arkansas
did not put him in office they didn't
put him in a suit they didn't put him
anywhere near a place of business he's
in a parking lot
on a ford mustang giving you advice
about the vaccine
continue during the pandemic my
lifestyle drastically changed my income
came to a screeching halt you have to
understand i'm a hustler i'm a legit
entrepreneur i sell things what do you
do i come in contact with people all the
time
what's your job to stay safe i didn't
have a choice but to trust the vaccine
if you live the type of lifestyle that i
live doing
hustling why not do it safely what is
your job
what job description is quote out here
in these streets
this is from the arkansas department of
health
what career
is described as i'm quote hustling
out here in these streets they're making
them seem like a drug deal
this is literally saying if you are also
a drug dealer
get the vaccine i mean that's literally
what it's saying
they're going hey if you sell drugs
you may not think it's important to get
the vaccine but you should
there is by the way there is no attempt
to make this guy seem like he has a job
that anyone would understand as legit
his his job description is if you are
out here
hustling in these streets selling things
and coming into contact with people all
the time
get the vaccine what may i ask
are you doing in these streets
i mean let's let's go through this again
i
i can almost not believe this start over
okay are you sure we're not being
trolled this is real
yeah let's let's just double check here
because they were playing it before
youtube videos yet
i was seeing it played before youtube
videos as ads
so yeah and they've turned the comments
off i wonder why they've done that
and it says right here on youtube from
state public health authority
jesus that's crazy okay keep going this
is hilarious okay
during the pandemic my lifestyle
drastically changed my income came to a
screeching halt you have to understand
i'm a hustler i'm a legit entrepreneur i
sell things
i come in contact with people all the
time i have to stay safe
i didn't have a choice but to trust the
vaccine if you live the type of
lifestyle that i live
you're out here in these streets and
you're hustling an entrepreneur like me
why not do it safely so i want everybody
to take this seriously
take a shot at staying healthy take a
shot
wouldn't it be funny if he it was like a
gang war at the end that's the weird
take a shot like should he even like
take a shot
just like that with the gun like right
to the camera
it seems odd i don't believe we're
getting trolled because youtube like has
anyone talked about this at all
i saw it go somewhat viral on twitter uh
yeah but other than
i found it on youtube and it played
before people's youtube ads they were
screen recording it and like sharing it
on tiktok and twitter
god take a shot
at staying healthy
well
cummings response [ __ ] i've been dead
for 12 years
she wins
hey man i hope you're doing well my
friend who's coming to austin's looking
for food good food recommendations yet
don't come
[Music]
my abusive stepfather made the best
salsa why i've reclaimed this recipe is
my own this was in today from the ages
of 12 to 22 i was stalked and harassed
by an anonymous predator the person
hacked my email sent me explicit
packages
and broken my apartment steal my laundry
and diaries for years i lived in terra
not knowing
who would do this to me or why finally
nearly a decade of mystery the truth
came out the perpetrator
of these disturbing actions was my own
stepfather and i told that
on the today show in 2019 my now former
stepfather has been in prison for these
and other crimes for 14 years he also
bankrupted my mother
stole hundreds of thousands from his
financial planning clients and possessed
child pornography
in the intervening years i've more or
less succeeded in putting him out of my
mind although
i talk openly about him he he doesn't
fill my thoughts
and i don't dwell on the memories of him
okay and that should have been the end
that should have been the end right that
should have been the end
but not too long ago i stumbled upon his
old prized homemade salsa recipe
one our family used to beg him to make
for parties and get-togethers
all these memories of this particular
food came flooding back poolside
hangouts over a big bowl of chips
and salsa with my cousins new year's eve
appetizer spread
fourth of july celebrations dipping and
crunching under the light of fire hey by
the way
get this guy out of jail can this be
introduced at a parole hearing
they should be introduced in a parole
hearing he should be let out of jail
because of this
being a food writer and an all-around
food uh lover i couldn't resist making
the sauce for myself and lo and behold
it was every bit as amazing as i
remembered
the zesty flavor combo of fresh tomato
cilantro and onion
and the minced pico de gallo like
texture remained as irresistible as they
were in my last adolescence when
presumably
she was being hunted by a predator looks
good it does look great
but despite the perfection of gary's
famous house uh making it brought up
some conflicting emotions sure it was
restaurant quality but i had to wonder
if i included this recipe in my own
cooking repertoire would it always
remind me of the horrors of my
stepfather could i ever look
at its jewel-toned blend of veggies
without flashing
back to the pain of my past after giving
it some thought i came to a decision
instead of thinking about this delicious
dip as a sole property of my abuser
maybe i could make it my own i never had
many family recipes passed down to me so
maybe this one could be a family recipe
in the truest raw sense one that bears
the scars of my past but reveals my
resilience too
that's the kind of recipe i'd like to
pass down to my children the more i make
the salsa the less it bears my abuser's
imprint
i just love the idea of her handing it
down to her children and she goes listen
the salsa recipe i'm about to give you
comes from a very bad man a man who
would do
horrible things but one thing he didn't
do
was make bad salsa
he was abusive he was a pedophile he
bankrupted your grandmother
but what he didn't do was [ __ ] up a dip
i mean christ i wish her all the best
that's a real austin texas article she
should move to austin
i hope the dad gets out like i really
really hope that dad
gets out of prison because of this like
at the parole hearing he reads this
and and they have to try the salsa like
they're like okay he's in here for
possession of child pornography
and all these other things but like the
the parole board has to like they have
to take a bite of the salsa
and they start looking at each other and
by the way this is a fun reinvention of
the show top chef
finding out what pedophiles and prison
dishes that they were famous for
making them cook them and if there was
good as their victims remember they'd
get out
is there anything wrong with that
you know like
maybe there's a pedophile
who made a really good guac and
like they're like if you can get the
perfect match of lime
cilantro salt and pep i mean we don't
need your rotten away in here
by the way no one is working because of
the stimulus and that companies don't
want to pay
so why not get this guy out of jail
and and let him make salsa somewhere he
doesn't have to do it in a school
let him make salsa at a restaurant where
only
ugly adults work i knew a city with a
lot of
fours and fives working
i live very close to it i think that's
what you should do
tim miller comedy.com sorry about san
diego folks family thinks
you know what do you want me to do we're
coming back in december chicago there's
some tickets left
be there at the end of august patreon
episode will be out tomorrow
rothschild tier episode is out right now
with andrew sullivan
who's a great writer a very interesting
guy he pioneered blogging
on the internet we have a very
interesting talk about
the united states of america and where
it is we were thinking of releasing it
as the episode but
we thought everybody would be really
angry
at uh a serious interview after the
episode was late
for what are we going on 48 hours yeah
about 48 hours
but i want you to go buy his book and
his new book is called
out on a limb book by andrew sullivan
selected writings and uh he's all over
the place
gay somewhat conservative has hiv
it's for the iraq war but against it
liked obama but then
realized the uh limits of obama
he's killing it over on sub stack where
all those
journalists are did you see a little
beef between uh
brett weinstein and sam harris over the
vax
there was a little put that
beef on the grill i don't want to go
into this i'm not a doctor
but i can i don't know if we can play
his channel here's the word no no don't
do anything there you you know
god only knows i would offer these
gentlemen something
if you want to debate the vaccine i will
dress like megan mccain and sodomize
myself
on my show while you guys debate the
vaccine
so if brett weinstein and sam harris
want to come on my
show and debate the vaccine i will take
a
dildo to my ass brutally
dress up like megan mccain to the point
where like i literally
[ __ ] myself on my own show
like in stirrups just [ __ ] wedging in
there
[ __ ] just and blood rivers is [ __ ] and
blood
all over the studio while you guys
discuss the vaccine
anyway open invite good night